مرجان فريمان مفاجاه قطر في حفل افتتاح
كاس العالم جدل حول ميريام فارس في
توكوتاكا السعوديه تحتفي بيوسف ثنيان
القاهره تواصل واحتفاء بالسينما وعيد
ميلاد السيده السابع والثمانون اليكمبرز
في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
انطلقت بطوله كاس العالم المنتظره لكره
القدم فيفا 2022 في قطر بحفل مبهر شهيده
استاد البيت امتد لثلاثين دقيقه وبحضور ما
يقدر ب 60 الف متفرج وحلق فوق استاد لعيب
تميمته كاس العالم الجديده والذي يقام
لاول مره في بلد عربي وادى خلال هذا الحدث
التاريخي المغني الكوري الجنوبي جون كوك
احد نجوم فرقه بي تي اس الشهيره اغنيه
حالمون بالشراكه مع المغني القطري فهد
الكبيسي وكانت مفاجاه الحفل مشاركه الممثل
الامريكي مورجان فريمان الذي وجهها مع
سفير النوايا الحسن القطري غانم المفتاح
دعوه للتنوع الشموليه والتقارب بين الشعوب
العالم وشمل برنامج حفل الافتتاح سبعه
فقرات امسج بين التقاليد القطريه والثقافه
العالميه وتحتفل بالمنتخبات الاثنين
والثلاثين المشاركه وبدول المستضيفه
السابقه لكاس العالم ومتطوعين البطوله
شارك بادائها المئات من المؤذنين والع فين
والراقصين وتتابعون اخبار مونديال قطر
2022 اولا باول على سي ان بالعربيه في
تغطيه خاصه لزميلين عبيده نفاع وعبد
الرحمن بالحيك
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اجواء كاس العالم الحماسيه حيث
انقسمت الاراء على مواقع التواصل في
العالم العربي حول اداء ميريام فارس
الراقص لاحدى اغنيات البطوله الرسميه
تكوتاكا وجلسه التصوير سباقاتها نشرتها
ميريام فارس عبر حسابي الرسمي على
انستجرام وادت الفنانه اللبنانيه الاغنيه
بالشراكه مع نيكي ميناج ومعلومه بالعربيه
والانجليزيه والاسبانيه وهي من انتاج
يونيفرسال اربك ميوزك المنتج وسيم ستايلبي
كاس العالم في حفل سبق حفل الافتتاح وتحدث
الفنانه اللبنانيه بالعربيه وسائل الاعلام
عربيه اخرى عن كواليس العمل على هذه
الاغنيه
انا عملت اللحن العربي همم انا عملت
التوزيع تبعه يعني كل الانسربنز العربيه
الشرقيه اللي عم تسمعوها هي توزيعه همم
اختي كتبت لي الكلام وكان عندي كم كلمه
على بالي اني افوتهم يعني مثلا سلام عليكم
كان بدي اقول للناس انه نحنا نحنا ايه جنس
سلام نحن الفنانين وين بدنا نروح مش بس
هلا يعني مش بس هالو سلام بيس وكان بدي
انه يقول يلا سوا كان بدي اجمع كل العالم
لا يجي لعنا على المدى القيس ليجوا على
قطر
الرياض بتاريخ نجم كره القدم السعودي يوسف
ثنيان في مسرحيه بعنوان الفيلسوف توصل له
الضوء على الامجاد التي حققها الاثنين مع
المنتخب السعودي ونادي الهلال لحظات
تاريخيه بذاكرتي دهن السعوديهين في
الثمانينيات
ومن قطر والسعوديه الى مصر حيث تتواصل
فعاليات الدوله 44 لمهرجان القاهره
السينمائي الدولي بعروض السينمائيه دوليه
وعربيه تستاثر باهتمام عشاق السينما في
المحروسه وتستنفذ مبكرا حجوزات شباك
التذاكر ومن ابرز العروض السينمائيه التي
قدمت في مهرجان القاهره ولاول مره في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا فيلم
السباحتان لسالي الحسيني الذي سيعرض قريبا
على منصه وتدور احداثه في اطار الانساني
حول رحله الخطيره التي خادت السباحه
السوريه يسرا مارديني واختها ساره من بلاد
مسقتها الحرب الى اولمبياد ريو دي جانيرو
بالعربيه غلطت فعاليات المهرجان من
القاهره وكان لها لقاءات مع نجوم صناع
السينما المصريه ومنهم المخرجه كامله ابو
ذكري في لقاء حول مسيرتها وتكريم المهرجان
لها هذا العام سينشر قريبا
واخيرا احتفل فيروزيون بعيد ميلاد
معشوقتهم الفنانه اللبنانيه فيروز السابع
والثامين في العشرين من نوفمبر وليس
الحادي والعشرين منه كما هو شائع وهذه
حقيقه تؤكد عليها ابنتها ريما عاصي
الرحباني كل عام وتمنح ريم عشاق السيده
ومحبيها على امتداد العالم العربي فرصه
معايتها برسائل الفيديو تعليقا على تدوينه
سنويا تنشرها الصفحه الرسميه لفيروز وربما
الاجمل هذا العام فيديو لسفيرتنا الى
النجوم الابنه لوالدتها وهي تضيء شمعه
وحيده على كعكه ميلادها وتنظر الى
الكاميرا ابتسامه خجوله بينما تشجع
السعاده من عينيها اللتين طالما تعلقت
بهما قلوب محبيها بينما تصدح اغنيه العيد
في الخلفيه قبل ان يختتم المشهد بصوت
ضحكتها